why do you think Nazis get such a bad
rap
because it was on video
[Music]
that's why I know because you can't deny
it you can't you can't just pretend it
didn't happen and not put it in the
history books they filmed the [__] right
because they thought they were going to
win you know what else thought they were
going to win the Catholic Church
and they wanted him to win because they
want to take out a whole religion that
was good for their business and then all
of a sudden they [__] lost and then
they had to give back the golden [__] to
the families like oh sorry about that oh
is that us oh yeah
you ever read about that yeah I'm gonna
no they found [__] dead Jewish
people's belongings and all that all of
the good [__] not the clothes they
didn't give a [__] about that but the
the [__] that was worth money they found
in the Vatican some of it not all of it
you're gonna see the new Indiana Jones
foreign
[Applause]